il était une fois un petit garçon appelé
momo qui vivait dans un cirque c'est une
histoire simple mais en même temps qui
est important c'est que un enfant qui
qui ont dit voilà il va il va prendre la
relève de son grand-père il sera cloud
et lui son souhait c'est d'être
acrobates
ils ne vont pas très bien sans doute a
dit je n'aime pas le clown
tout ce qu'il veut c'est faire une chose
face être accro pas donc pas du tout ce
qui a été prévu pour lui quoi et il va y
va donc devoir se battre contre ce grand
père et
est arrivé à avait faire entendre que
c'est vraiment un chrono qui veut être
est ce que le grand-père de reconnaître
à la fin momo commença à se balancer
dans les airs d'avant en arrière
en avant
à l'origine de mon un livre disque pour
enfants sorti en 1996 les morceaux sont
signées pascal dusapin compositeurs
contemporains
c'est un spectacle on a créé il ya dix
ans exactement là quasiment jour pour
jour en novembre 2010 tout cet univers
du cirque est vraiment traité de façon
poétique ce soit donc avec les animaux
qu'on voit derrière ce cyclo les
éléments comme ça
qui font partie du cirque
acrobatie et c'est le cloud bien sûr
c'est vrai qu'en même temps c'est assez
simple et il ya beaucoup de ce à travers
pas mal de choses quoi la musique le
cirque le jeu et le théâtre d'ombrés
sans oublier l'interactivité avec le
jeune public et la sensibilisation aux
instruments de musique comme la
clarinette la mandoline ou le
violoncelle momo un spectacle musical
alliant humour et poésie à voir au
théâtre de saint quentin vendredi 9 et
samedi 10 novembre